Jesse Holmes devotes all of his time
money and resources to his team of sled
dogs winter racing season will begin
soon and getting his dog lot in working
order is a priority this is gonna be one
clean open area with everything in rows
this time step this up the weather is
completely changed we're heading into
early winter the grounds freezing can't
take this top layer this ground off and
he stumps out on the frozen ground so
timings everything is with anything up
here
what up hey how you doing man you ready
my friends willing to help me right now
that's huge because this job that it's
doing for me is not something that I
could do myself
I don't own a piece of machinery I've
got way too many dogs that just have
dogs strewn all over the place in the
woods tripping holes
I mean I'm liable to break my leg out
here and when these holes this winter
and in my hole mushing career it's got
to become professional organized so I
can deal with it efficiently to actually
be able to see all my main dogs in a
movie racing this year in one spot is
gonna be an exciting thing everything in
rows it's gonna look amazing it's gonna
make my life ten times easier
you